i don't know if it's become sort of a
cheesy line to say that a certain show
or anime in some way changed you or
helped you through a tough time in your
life the profound idea that a piece of
entertainment could have such a tangible
effect that it helps shapes you and even
if you may change grow older grow more
mature you still carry a piece of it
with you years after you watch it
i'm sure many of you have one or two
things that have done that for you but
in anime i don't think there's a
franchise that has touched and
influenced as big of an audience as
evangelion evangelion is quite possibly
my favorite anime of all time or at
least it's the one i've carried with me
for the longest and i know that's not
really a hot take considering this is
arguably the most influential anime of
all time but i still do think it's a
series every anime fan needs to
experience at least once in their lives
not because i think everyone will
instantly love it as a universally
acclaimed masterpiece but because it's
such a profoundly powerful and intimate
piece of media that if by chance you do
come out of this resonating with a
character or a scene or maybe just a
single line
it'll stick with you for a very very
long time
it's touched many lives in a way no
other piece of media has or ever will
and i think it'd be a massive shame if
there was even a chance of anyone
depriving themselves of that experience
i say this but i actually hated it the
first two times i watched it because i
think the worst thing that ava does is
that it genuinely builds up this
interesting world and mystery and it
just sets the wrong expectations i
remember thinking man this is such a
cool world i can't wait till they
explain where the angels come from what
the dead sea scrolls are the lands of
longinus what's gonna happen to the
characters and how are they gonna
resolve all their problems and then
none of that happened the ending that
was meant to conclude it did the
opposite the tv series ending at the
time felt like a low budget therapy
session tacked on because the studio ran
out of money and the end of evangelion
movie was to me a
self-masturbatory pretentious mind [ __ ]
that left me less satisfied than when i
started it i came into ava expecting a
traditional story and i went out
confused and unfulfilled i had so many
questions and zero answers i was angry
that i had gotten invested in the series
in the first place i spent days
researching reading explanations getting
into online arguments and i left even
more confused i could not understand how
a series like this got the critical
claim that it did and that's how it was
for me for the longest time
then
years later i entered the darkest period
of my life
several massive things happened to me
and i was in the worst mental state i'd
ever been in and ever have been in still
nothing could pick me up from this well
i'd fallen into my favorite anime lost
their magic games were no longer fun
everything just kind of felt meaningless
and for some reason i decided to put on
evangelion because hell
why the [ __ ] not right this time though
something just clicked i no longer cared
about the mysteries or the lore of the
world i saw broken people trying to find
value in who they were i saw pieces of
myself spread out in every character and
the fever dream artsy sequences i
dismissed as pretentious before somehow
made sense
it was like someone had laid out my
jumbled fractured stream of
consciousness and put it on screen
for the first time i actually started to
understand it and by understand i don't
just mean that i suddenly had an
epiphany that allowed me to comprehend
every small line in detail but it felt
like on some level i could empathize
with what these characters were feeling
with what the creator was trying to say
it felt like someone understood the pain
i was going through and in a way that
gave me comfort
to me in some twisted way it made me
feel like i might have been suffering
but at least there was someone out there
who could empathize with this pain i was
feeling someone else had felt what i was
feeling right now
my life wasn't suddenly cured but a lot
of things just mentally clicked together
and
at least for a period
it gave me a sense of tranquility
and i think that's the real power of
evangelion
when people say you don't get evangelion
i used to think that it was a
pretentious way of attacking my
intelligence that i somehow couldn't
comprehend
what was going on but now i just think
it just means that you don't resonate
with the emotions being portrayed on
screen because to me there's no real way
you can truly understand ava i've
watched a lot of people far smarter and
more attentive than i ever will be
analyze every single character broken
down its themes and symbolism spent
hours upon hours breaking down every
single part of this franchise and i
still
don't fully understand ava but i'm fine
with that because i think by design i
don't know if it's even meant to be
something you can comprehend in a
traditional sense
it's quite well known that the creator
hideakiano was in an awful state of mind
when he made it and i can never ignore
this because i remember during that
period in my life little if anything
made sense at all emotions don't always
make sense and that's what i feel from
this show i don't see someone trying to
lay out a coherent narrative meant to be
understood i see a guttural cry for help
i see someone trying so desperately to
find resolution to their own internal
struggles more than any other series
i've seen this feels like someone laying
their feelings bare in front of us for
no other purpose other than the
catharsis of expressing themselves and
this is something i can personally
relate to i think the most powerful
thing i've ever made to date is this amv
called reflections of despair
it's still on youtube now but it's
something that i made during that dark
period and i made it for no reason other
than
i just needed to i needed to vent i
needed to put my pain into something i
didn't have anyone to talk to i didn't
have anyone to pick me up so i sat in my
room alone for two days straight putting
my emotions into the editing timeline of
this video
to me it was my way of crying for help
i was screaming in total silence
i am still incredibly proud of this amv
even if i don't recognize the person who
made it sure i know i did i literally
remember doing it but i couldn't
recreate something like this even if i
tried for better or worse i'm thankfully
in a much better place now and looking
back at this i don't know what i was
trying to say i don't know why i picked
the lines i did why i chose these scenes
or why i use this song all i know is
that
it felt right
at the time i realized this isn't
comparable to making a full tv series
but this is what i feel from every
iteration of ava perhaps anno did know
exactly what he wanted to say perhaps he
didn't but what i always feel is the
catharsis of his raw unbridled emotions
etched into the show it's so strongly
imbued with these emotions that if
you've ever related even just a little
bit it's impossible to not have some
kind of guttural reaction to it to use
it as a springboard to reflect on
yourself
every time i've watched evangelion i've
come out with something new and there's
just something special about a series
that can teach me something new about
myself every single time i watch it if
there was one thing i never got from ava
however it was that feeling of a
satisfying end at least naturally as you
grow older you realize that not
everything in life has a clean ending
not everything has a perfect solution
and that's fine
sometimes you just learn to live with it
and move on and that's exactly what
happens with me and ava which brings me
to my motivation of making this video in
the first place which is the final
evangelion film that just got its
release worldwide avangelion 3.0 plus
1.0 my hype for the final ava movie died
a long time ago at first i was giddy at
the possibility of having a proper
ending and then three films took five
years to make and then after that one
year passed
then two years then five years and now
almost 10 years after 3.0 came out my
initial reaction to it getting released
was
oh
it's out by this point in life i had
made peace with the franchise i could
have gotten no more ava in my life at
all and i would have been completely
fine with it i was no longer invested
enough to even care how it concluded
which is why i'm so blindsided by how
much this movie meant for me this didn't
just feel like 9 years in the making it
felt like 26 years in the making and i
can't even begin to describe the
cathartic release of feeling what i
never got to feel over half my lifetime
ago now when i first watched ava
closure
was it the perfect movie no
was every little thing resolved no was
it even my favorite ending no but it was
one that i'd forgotten that i was
waiting for i have no shame in admitting
that i didn't understand most of what
was going on but like i've said to me
ava was never a series about the perfect
narrative understanding every plot point
or tying up all loose ends it was about
emotional resonance and what resonated
with me was someone who had truly found
a way to move past their inner demons in
the original eva shinji learned to
accept who he was and love himself and
every ending kind of replicates that
same sentiment but this time it felt
different because it really felt like
the person behind him saying it
had time to properly believe it you
don't just wake up one day and be okay
with the world you don't just take one
pill and wish goodbye to depression you
don't just have one pep talk
and realize that everything that was
broken about you
is now fixed
so
experiencing the work of the same guy
who made ava 26 years later and not just
seeing but actually feeling a completely
different person retelling the story a
happier person exuding through this
final ending i
actually couldn't be more delighted i
couldn't be happier that someone like me
had
found a way to move on i don't know how
i could possibly convey the feeling of
having a franchise that meant so much to
you that stuck with you for years that
you'd made peace with that you thought
would always be there
coming to an end
i felt happy that i got to experience
such an amazing journey in the first
place i felt sad because i felt like i
was finally putting an aspect of my
younger self to rest for good i felt
empty because this was it this was truly
the end
but most of all i felt fulfilled
in a way only ava could make me feel
in the end to me ava was a passionate
way for one man to lay his raw emotions
and ideas out there it's the story of a
broken man on his journey to solace as a
fan you view this journey through foggy
glasses you spend your time figuring out
where he was going with all this you
guess second guess analyze creep in for
a closer look research analyze over
every detail ponder over whether it
means anything at all question why you
give a damn in the first place only to
realize that in the end
it meant something to you
something about it spoke to you
that's just the baggage that came with
being an ava fan because whatever
message you take from the franchise from
the endings from any of the iterations
it is and always will be
your own
this is a series that will probably
stick with me for the rest of my life
but i've grown up and moved on to a
world without ava even so i couldn't be
more thankful that i was given one last
opportunity to properly put a rest to
that part of my life and in the end
i don't think there's anything more i
can say
other than
goodbye
and thank you
all
of evangelion
[Music]
you